[Aplausos]
es que este que te quite que todo el día
tiki tiki con el celular ese era el
reclamo de mi mamá y de mi papá durante
gran parte de mi adolescencia y si
pasaba mucho tiempo con el celular pero
lo que no sabían es que en realidad
estaba yendo detrás de lo que me gustaba
pero déjate de y por ésta tuviera
sé lo que tienes que hacer y si también
lo hacía de hecho descubrí que era eso
que me gustaba estando en el colegio
de chico me apasionaba el fútbol hincha
fanático de boca me dio lo máximo ahora
palermo pero yo no la acción gol y el
arco iris también me gustaba mucho la
música y si bien tomé clases de guitarra
lo cierto es que nunca fui lo
suficientemente constante o bueno como
para destacarme en eso fue una clase de
lengua y literatura en la que la
profesora nos enseñó el género
entrevista ella nos dijo que la
entrevista tendría puentes nos servía
para conocer a las otras personas
conocer sus historias y a mí siempre me
gustó conocer personas y creo que todos
tenemos algo que contar
fue eso lo que me despertó curiosidad y
las ganas de querer yo también poder
hacer entrevistas de entrevistar a esos
artistas esas personas que admiraba y
que quizás sentía un toque les ganas
cual iluso empecé a mandar mails a
cuanto medio conocía y la mayoría de
ellos no me contestaron los que lo
hicieron me exigían título universitario
experiencia previa
conocimientos en diseño
residencia en buenos aires lluvia acá en
rafaela que no no es el medio del campo
y si por eso me como las veces al final
de las palabras pero retomando lo que
les contaba en otras palabras los medios
tradicionales me mandaron a tomar la
mamadera sin embargo yo como todo
adolescente que le cuesta
residuo no dije no
yo quiero hacer eso y casi que inspirado
en el eslogan de la marca del logo de la
pipa nike
decide hacerlo yo mismo creó un blog y
lo llamé sos tan beatle
de los que están acá quiero preguntarles
levanten la mano quienes al volver del
colegio
practicaban algún deporte fútbol básquet
handball
bien
yo llegaba a casa me sacaba el uniforme
los zapatos que me apretaba prendía la
compu abría mi email tomic john bock a
97 arroba hotmail.com y me sentaba a
redactar mails hola mi nombre es tomás
sal tina soy director de la revista
digital soft ámbito y me gustaría
entrevistarte será posible yo hasta
entonces no había hecho una entrevista y
lo más cercano reseñar a un disco había
sido el análisis sintáctico oraciones
me movían las ganas de hacer y aprender
la primera persona a la que le conté el
proyecto fue una amiga de lo que vamos
al mismo colegio y compartíamos el mismo
gusto por las bandas la literatura la
escritura ella siempre fue mucho más
talentosa que yo
y si bien el proyecto todavía ha estado
en pañales
no dudó en sumarse
empezamos entrevistando artistas
emergentes a los que muchas veces los
medios no le daban un lugar y para
nosotros era súper importante porque
estábamos aprendiendo -es y de vuelta
nos sumaba un montón ya cuando se
trataba de un artista reconocido
era más difícil porque desconfiaban
chicos de 15 años queriendo hacer una
entrevista
sospechaban que éramos fanáticos y que
simplemente queríamos conocerlos pero
nosotros insistíamos si el primer mail
no respondía mandamos
234 y cada tanto alguno picada
al poco tiempo estábamos entrevistando a
artistas de la talla del pintor miranda
tan biónica y no podíamos creer éramos
dos puberto teníamos quince años y
estábamos llegando a sus artistas que
digamos súper lejanos porque claro
vivíamos en rafaela y acá muchas veces
no llegaban
las entrevistas las hacíamos por
videollamada por teléfono o por mail y
contadas veces cuando alguno hacía un
show en la ciudad la podíamos concretar
personalmente
fue en ese momento cuando nos dimos
cuenta de que no necesitábamos cumplir
con ninguno de los requisitos que los
medios tradicionales nos exigían para
poder hacer eso que nos gustaba
no teníamos un título universitario
tampoco experiencia previa muchos menos
conocimientos en diseño no vivíamos en
buenos aires pero sí teníamos una
computadora conexión a internet
cuentan instará en facebook en twitter y
ahora también un blog
de que todo el día tiki tiki con el
celular
mis papás no entendía muy bien qué era
eso que hacía
pensaba que el tiempo que pasaba
enfrente la pantalla era tiempo perdido
me insistían con que mi prioridad tenía
que ser el estudio que tenía que
enfocarme en eso y no perder el tiempo
con cosas que no me sumaban por el
contrario para mí el tiempo que pasaba
con el celular con la computadora era
sinónimo de aprendizaje y de crecimiento
para ese entonces ya habíamos hecho
contacto con managers con prensas
discográficas que ahora pasaban a
ofrecernos entradas para los recitales
para que podamos ir a cubrirlos pero
claro estábamos lejos la mayoría eran en
buenos aires en córdoba rosario
y fue gracias a las redes sociales que
conectamos con otros chicos y chicas de
la misma que nosotros con esas mismas
ganas de hacer y desarrollarse no solo
la comunicación sino también en el
diseño en vídeo
fotografía
y fue entonces cuando stv dejó de ser un
proyecto personal para convertirse en un
proyecto colectivo con chicos en
rosario-buenos aires
córdoba san luis tucumán
chile méjico
nosotros nos terminábamos de entender un
poco el impacto que eso tenía
cuando terminé la secundaria
decidí irme a estudiar comunicación a
buenos aires
toda persona que es del interior sabe el
esfuerzo que significa por eso estuviera
afuera y para mis papás
fue un esfuerzo enorme
esa oportunidad es algo que yo valoro y
agradezco un montón
para mí llegar a buenos aires fue
descubrir un mundo nuevo hasta entonces
lo había visitado dos o tres veces una
por un viaje de estudio y otras dos por
amor si me enamoré a distancia pero esa
es otra historia
lo cierto es que todo todo todo me
llamaba la atención
es colectivo el subte la gente yendo y
viniendo en la calle con los pelos de
colores hasta que yo también me termine
teniendo el pelo de color
y para ese entonces
también pudimos conocernos con esos
chicos y chicas que se habían sumado al
equipo y con los que habíamos entablado
una relación de amistad a la distancia
pero tan fuerte que parecía que nos
conocíamos hacia un montón
ahora las entrevistas las hacíamos
personales con esas bandas o artistas
que nos gustaban y que ya antes habíamos
querido entrevistar y quizás por a o por
b no se podía más la fama paulo londra
llegamos a conocer artistas
internacionales como the strokes timing
para la
empezamos a abordar también otros ejes
como literatura cine sociedad de hecho
una vez fuimos a cubrir un avant
première a al four seasons el hotel
machito de buenos aires
entre los medios estaban crónicas el
trece telefé c5n y los otros dos también
rick pitino no conocía nadie
la entrevista era con las chinas suárez
y benjamín vicuña después del escándalo
del motorhome
pizarro
al día siguiente todos los diarios de
chimentos subía en la pregunta que
habíamos hecho no entendíamos nada
estamos haciendo 10 entrevistas por
semana un montón
coberturas reseñas
y para mí eso implicaba tener que
coordinar esas entrevistas coordinar las
reseñas hacerlas subirlas compartirlas
en redes sociales llegó un momento en el
que me sentía abrumado
quizás me juntaba a tomar una birra con
amigos y tenía que estar pendiente del
celular me desconectaba de lo que estaba
pasando alrededor ya había dejado de
disfrutar entonces llegó un momento en
el que dije basta chicos no dije pasta
así no puedo seguir
había llegado el momento de tomarnos un
tiempo de hacer una pausa en ese
proyecto que tanto me había dado y que
me acompañó durante tantos años a mí y
un montón de otros chicos y chicas
durante nuestra adolescencia durante
nuestro crecimiento
todos me decían tienes que disfrutar
tenés que salir divertirte levanten la
mano los que están acá a quienes les
gusta salir a bailar
bueno yo nunca no no es que no me gusta
nunca me sentí como en el boliche
tradicional la mirada del otro la pose
el la entrada cara llegar tarde porque
se estira la previa a ir dos horas y la
música el código de vestimenta no me
encontraba por eso no iba boliches
tiene que haber otra manera de salir
encontrarse disfrutar sin esos códigos
que quizá a mí me limitaba y me di
cuenta que mi grupo amigos también
así que con las mismas personas que
hacíamos asustan beatle empezamos a
hacer una fiesta ruda que nunca va a ser
de la pista de baile un espacio de
expresión y de encuentro una entrada
accesible sin código de vestimenta en la
que cada cual iba a disfrutar
llegamos a hacer 15 ediciones de esas
fiestas algunas resultaron mejor otra
peor lo cierto que nosotros estábamos
disfrutando y eso era lo importante
también nos dábamos cuenta que los
festivales de música que muchas veces
cubríamos
repetían siempre los mismos nombres que
si nos gustaban pero se volvía al como
no público era siempre la misma banda
sonando arriba los escenarios y solo
música no no no pasa otra cosa más que
eso entonces decidimos hacer también un
festival que le dé lugar a artistas
nuevos que renueve la escena
les llamamos elementos en su primera
edición reunió más de 15 artistas de
distintas disciplinas no solo música
sino también fotografía artes plásticas
cortometrajes poesía
y si bien coto lo cierto es que al día
de la fecha las entradas estaban
agotadas
no lo pudimos creer
lo que para muchos empresarios hubiese
sido un fracaso para nosotros había sido
un éxito porque no habíamos generado
ganancias en mano nos quedamos con un
peso pero logramos hablar los gastos
pagarle a todos los artistas y cada cual
se fue contento a su casa y otra vez
tanto ruda como 'elemento lo hicimos de
forma presencial pero desde las redes
sociales
de que todo el día tiki tiki con el
celular
ya sea a fines de 2019 nos cansamos de
bailar y casi que anticipándonos a la
pandemia decidimos que era un buen
momento para relanzar su stand beatle
sabíamos que para hacerlo teníamos que
repensar las bases pero esta vez
contábamos con la experiencia previa a
los aprendizajes no sólo eso también
tells y no facultativos laborales que
cada uno hizo en paralelo
y lo más importante
tenemos un grupo un grupo de amigos y
amigas
que confiábamos el uno en el otro y que
también confiábamos en el proyecto y que
los siete días de la semana nos
juntábamos a hacernos preguntas que eso
es tan vital como hacemos lo que hacemos
a quien le hablamos y quizás la más
importante porque hacemos lo que hacemos
en febrero 2020 justo antes de relanzar
el proyecto me llegó una propuesta
laboral
y si bien hasta el momento nunca me
había imaginado en una oficina dije
quizás es un buen momento para agarrar
la pala
semanas más tarde me sume al equipo de
experiencia de usuario de una de las
empresas de e-commerce más grande de
latinoamérica
gracias a que me hicieron un lugar en su
equipo con tan sólo 22 años un título
universitario en curso pero un puñado de
experiencias personales conmigo están
beatle ruda elemento
fue en ese momento cuando mi mamá y mi
papá se dieron cuenta de lo que había
hecho y fueron ellos los que esta vez me
dijeron ahora que empezás a trabajar no
dejes de lado soft ámbito
y fue con la pandemia de kobe 19 la
oblea del trabajo remoto y todo lo que
eso conllevó que entendieron
que usar el celular usar la computadora
no necesariamente es sinónimo de perder
el tiempo sino que el impacto que estos
tengan en nuestro día a día
depende del uso que nosotros hagamos de
ellos
hoy somos más de 20 personas las que
hicimos al equipo de sol tan vital
todos llegamos de diferentes maneras
pero no suelen las ganas de hacer y de
crecer en eso que hacemos
abrazamos las diferencias y hacemos de
ellas nuestra mayor riqueza
somos parte de una generación curiosa
inquieta nacidos entre finales de los 90
y principios de los 2000 somos centenial
nos dejamos llevar por lo que nos
apasiona cuestionamos lo establecido y
queremos cambiar las cosas
y si bien cada cual llegó de diferentes
maneras al proyecto coincidimos en que
fue un paso buscado y necesario una
ficha de dominó que empujó todas las
demás porque somos nosotros lo que
hacemos que las cosas pasen
[Aplausos]